un robot collaboratif pour transporter
des outils sur une chaîne de montage un
chariot élévateur fonctionnant seul ou
un drone programmé pour l'inventaire des
pièces bienvenue dans l' usine
automobile du futur développé depuis
2016 trois quarts de ces technologies
sont déployés dans les usines renault
objectif améliorer la performance
industrielle des sites de production
premier point c'est sur la sécurité
vous l'avez vu ici à plein
d'illustrations sur l'amélioration de la
sécurité sur la bière lioration des
revenants deuxième point majeur sur la
qualité des produits que l'on délivre le
fait d'avoir une qualité maîtrisée sur
l'ensemble de notre production et enfin
le troisième point c'est notre
performance finalement financière pour
faire les produits les moins chers
possibles
ces technologies sont développées dans
les usines en collaborant avec des
entreprises
c'est le cas de ce robot collaboratif un
système de vision pour contrôler la
qualité des pièces ici on va venir voir
si les coutures sont bien placés le
contrôle d'après on va voir si à
l'instar de la porte qu'on allait les
bons caractère qui sont sur les poignets
l'industrie 4.0 s'est aussi connecté les
collaborateurs entre suivre en temps
réel la production de la commande du
véhicule à la livraison ou encore tester
l'implantation de nouveaux outils grâce
à la réalité virtuelle
par exemple je veux voir si lilo pourra
être implanté on s'aperçoit ici qu on
ait limites
by poteaux en béton de lusine donc avec
ceux ci on va pouvoir faire un rapport
voilà j'ai fait une mesure qui me permet
de savoir le positionnement je veux
avoir entre mavericks et l' usine à
terme le déploiement de ces technologies
se ferait à l'échelle de l'alliance
renault nissan mitsubishi
prochain défi le développement de
l'utilisation des données et de
l'intelligence artificielle